non è vero che su fa vj non c'è quality
contento perché ieri ho portato
overwatch che è un gioco della madonna
oggi vi lanciamo un po la cosa ho
sentito il profumo del quality content
che arriva io sento puzza proprio di
mezzi pronti raga 3 2 1 la città non
sarei che come descriverla io sta roba
c'è talmente tanto schifo insieme che
non sono anche laddove inizia la canzone
dx file di sottofondo il menù che sembra
fatto da un bambino di due anni la
scrisse manco le scritte va bene play
nel centro lancia zecca nulla niente
però play va bene perché faccio lo
youtuber quando potevo non nascere
ragazzi miei libri cosa sto vedendo dio
ma roba da sul serio la fa veramente
così schifo stesse fa e va bene mister
naso gigante senza corpo con le gambe
gioco della vita
credo abbiate riconosciuto più al solo
morto tra l'altro vi direte ma si vede
che qualcuno ha visto getting over it ha
deciso di fare un gioco da schifo che ci
somiglia non avrà fatto in cinque minuti
ma ci credete se vi dico che in realtà
getting over it è ispirato a questo
gioco e non sto scherzando cete spiegami
come e da dove mi chi è uscito questo
schifo così a questo abominio
videoludico peraltro neanche va bene ok
ragazzi oggi finiremo questo gioco che
si chiama tal altro nemico non è anche
il nome di sta roba
niente non esca anche a superare
l'albero fantastico gioco fatto con
paint ci avranno messo ormai dire un
pomeriggio è tanto secondo me
parlo problema che non riesco a superare
neanche la prima parte
porca vacca non sono anche le braccia le
mani non sono attaccata al corpo a una
cosa positiva in tutto questo comunque
c'è
non ho speso soldi per questo gioco
perché non costa niente almeno quello
sporco demonio
sono vivo calmi tutti zitti
mammamia guarda lì ho il computer omen
della hp che mi girano player non batte
grande su 4 schermi e invece gioco a
questo fantastico
non è che supereremo anche il primo
punto ma basta 4 milioni di iscritti sei
anni su youtube buttati nel cesso in un
video sopra cosa sta succedendo nel
mondo di dio
ricordatevi ragazzi che gesù si è
sacrificato per noi è il risultato è
questo ma come si passa da lì porco
demonio morton terra primo punto del
gioco riesco a passare il primo l'inizio
la ragazza veramente ma come cazzo come
possibile o no sta matta ammazzo sali
veloce oggi al tuo culo flaccido lì che
non è un cell è neanche il culo
probabilmente ok o vai avanti
vai avanti dios c veramente non ho
parole come faccio a arriva alla sua
aiuto ma se vado a destra perché o
indietro vado a destra i olona sinistra
per l'amore di gesù niente lui va
sinistro
vai a destra perché voi a sinistra
benigne chiave schifo sta roba
segui comandi ma dalla nostra musica mi
sta snervando ve lo giuro
[Musica]
fa meglio sto gioco del the ballet o
anche staccato le cuffie audio
non so se si è staccato l'audio perché
si sono staccate le cuffie in tal caso
vi faccio io con la bocca e rumori di
che sta facendo
ma questo è il massimo che posso
ricavare la sto gioco è mai possibile
che un gioco sia così brutto come fai
come fai a dimenticarti di mettere
l'erba sul su un cubo cioè ma possibile
quando gioca così ben curato come fai
dimenticarti quel dettaglio le età e ma
non riesco non si può tua madre quino di
dio ma don orione di quanto sei brutto
stop e lato o coma pietro impalato però
poi quanto deve essere difficile ma
perché ho sia lodato il signore tutti
gli angeli ci voglio veramente credere
che cos'è sta roba
cos'è comunque uguale a pietro e non
veridici di veneti ti schiaffeggia la
famiglia con i piedi
no raga mikado troppo perché tanto non
tornò più qui c'è lo so già io non posso
toccare poteva anche uccidermi e se va
beh
se quella roba lì si vabbè va bene così
ho fatta salire la sopra ma poi è
impossibile perché c'è un pezzo di sopra
ancora come ma come faccio non c'è un
punto dove stare col culo a quelle con
le persone poco normali che ci giocano
come fanno dai dai
ma non riesco neanche ma più si muove
con una lentezza sto martello che fa
veramente schifo agli scarafaggi ma c'è
veramente io muovo il mouse come siamo
il martello ma cos'è porco schifo ma dai
9 ne valeva sinistro viva sinistro
perché ve deciso di andare a sinistra
perché sua madre pulsa per quello non ho
neanche le cuffie da lanciare non è un
tir a lanciare questo non possa lanciare
quel vecchio nel vecchio quindi si rompe
di niente non posso fare niente possono
chiudere il canale più facile vincere o
per voce contro thomas veramente o o
adesso adesso devo andare lì su e per
andare a visto devo fare così che però
non ci arrivo perché ciò il microfono e
in mezzo ai con ciò non era veramente
ecco mi scrivi e cosa vuoi dalla mia
vita lì è però poi mi chiamai avanti ma
come fanno ma come fai ma non è così
l'avete visto ma vi giuro su dio che non
è così fa cioè in vera mente impossibile
ma è un ma ci posso provare anche tutto
il giorno non ci riuscirò mai non riesco
non me lo fa quello che fai l'altro
amerò lo fa ho giocate apriranno non
fatemi vedere che state giocando della
roba fatta bene e basta basta io
veramente ho giocato allo scempio allo
scempio ancora come vito ragazzi non mi
voglio non voglio mai più sentire
parlare a proposito forse faranno una
mappa di getting over it è nuova se però
ci mettono un botto a farla
nel frattempo ci siamo consultati con
questa roba tra liti content welcome
dovete ragazzi come se serviva per il
momento mi piace anche a bari
essenziale sapere se siete vi e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video senza martelli
senza nasi bei ragazzi gesù
[Musica]